The voicemail number that you can call 24
hours a day is 2 1 9 2.
David P..
Here is a protest.
Sorry.
Here's a caller who doesn't care if the protesters
die of Corona virus, but unfortunately, it's
more complicated than that.
Listen, David, I know this is sort of unpopular
to say, especially with like knowing your
views, but honestly, dude.
I don't care if some of these protesters die
as a result of their irresponsible actions.
I get it.
The problem is other people will also die.
I'm mostly on board with if this is truly
a sort of natural selection type thing where
if the protesters want to protest and they
are the only ones sick of at risk of getting
sick and dying at a certain point it's like,
OK, let them do it now.
The problem is some of them are bringing their
kids.
Are their kids really able to consent to that?
Do the kids really understand the risks?
I don't think so.
But if you imagine, only the protesters are
the ones that risk dying by protesting.
At a certain point, I would say, fine, just
let him do it.
The problem is they become spreaders of the
disease.
And so while you are right, you were also
missing that.
It's a fantasy to imagine that the protesters
are only putting themselves at risk.
That's the problem.
On today's bonus show, we will talk about
news that North Korean leader Kim Jong un
is very ill after surgery.
Yet another 2020 thing that is, is stacking
up for a very crazy situation.
We will also talk about what's going on amidst
the pandemic in Italy with the Mafia.
And we will talk about the Supreme Court guaranteeing
the right to a unanimous verdict in serious
criminal trials.
Very interesting and important.
All of those stories and more on today's bonus
show.
Don't miss it.
Get instant access by signing up at joint
PAC Mackoff.
The David Pakman Show David Pakman dot com.